we're going to turn now to a major
development in a key battle in the war
in ukraine we've been following the
plight of ukrainians trapped inside a
massive steel work facility in mariupol
surrounded by russian soldiers well
overnight president vladimir putin said
he was calling off a plan for those
soldiers to storm the facility he said
instead he was ordering a blockade but
as chris livesay reports from ukraine
the situation on the ground there is
still decidedly unclear chris good
morning
good morning tony the situation in
marieuple is the definition of dire
trapped inside a steel mill are hundreds
of soldiers and civilians women and
children left for dead and this morning
cbs news understands that some russian
forces have entered the mill that's been
their fortress going on two months but
not before they sent us this video
begging for help
for these women and children this
windowless maze of underground tunnels
beneath the azov stall steel mill has
become their bleak salvation
i wouldn't say this is the best
environment for children says this
mother of three their teeth are starting
to rot because they lack vitamin d
there's not enough sun
if it weren't for ukrainian soldiers
we'd have no food says this young mother
but both soldiers and food are running
out empty containers have become toys
famished children say they can't wait to
go to the grocery store
but it's been bombed by russian forces
like everything else in their city
turned into a hellscape
for weeks its defenders have repelled a
relentless russian onslaught that
surrounded the city thousands have died
from shelling
countless more from thirst and
starvation
others cut down as they tried to flee
ukrainians accused russian forces of
repeatedly breaking ceasefires even
targeting humanitarian corridors
this morning russian president vladimir
putin himself intervened ordering his
defense minister not to storm the mill
and risk losing russian lives instead
they must stiffen the blockade
block off this industrial area so that a
fly cannot pass through he commands
adding those who surrender will be
treated with respect
but considering similar russian
assurances in the past soldiers are
showing no sign of laying down their
arms
instead appealing for help from foreign
countries the u.n even the pope
we're maybe facing our final hours we're
outnumbered ten to one he says
please help us she begs and to those who
started this war against us i hope you
feel our pain on your own skin and that
your kids can feel this pain too
that person is of course vladimir putin
and not only is he escalating attacks
around marijuana in the eastern donbass
region the russian president has just
unveiled a new intercontinental missile
now it's still in the testing phase but
that's not stopping moscow from
deploying these images meant to scare
ukraine's allies jamie
scary indeed chris livesay in ukraine
thank you